FRANCESC: Hi, and
welcome on to episode
number 63 of the weekly
Google Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague, Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark.
How are you doing?
MARK: I'm good.
Thanks, Francesc.
How are you doing?
FRANCESC: Pretty good.
Waking up early for this today.
Joining from Pune in
India for GopherCon
and going soon to Mumbai.
MARK: Fun.
All right.
You're bouncing around a lot.
FRANCESC: Where in
the world are you?
MARK: Where in
I am sitting next to my
kitchen in my living room.
Yes.
I'm definitely jet setting.
That's fantastic.
FRANCESC: The jet lag between
the couch and the kitchen
is crazy.
MARK: Indeed.
FRANCESC: So we have a very,
very cool episode today
following the saga of
episodes about what
you can do with a programming
language on the cloud.
And today we have a developer
[INAUDIBLE] engineer, so one
of the roles that are part of
our division, the developer
relations, John Wayne Parrott.
And he's going to be
talking about Python.
MARK: Yeah.
He's going here today
to talk about Python.
I think that rounds out
the set of languages
that we have available
and generally
supported on our platform.
FRANCESC: I guess so, yeah.
We've done Ruby, Java, Go.
Have we done JavaScript?
MARK: We've done Node.js.
FRANCESC: Yeah, OK.
MARK: And PHP.
FRANCESC: Next, we
can go with Haskell.
MARK: Nice.
I'm down.
We should totally do that.
FRANCESC: I know.
It could be fun.
MARK: There's a GRPC
library for Haskell.
I'm just saying.
FRANCESC: There's a GRPC library
for basically any language.
That is the whole point.
MARK: All right.
So enough of our meandering.
Before we get into our
main content, however,
why don't we talk about--
there are a lot of cool
things this week, actually.
There are a lot of cool things.
FRANCESC: Yeah.
There's way too
many, so we actually
have to filter out
some of them, and we'll
let them for next week.
But we chose the three
most important ones
in our humble opinion.
MARK: In our humble
opinion, yeah.
So the first two are
all about hardware.
So the first time around, we
are-- a Google Cloud platform
is the first cloud provider
to offer Intel Skylake
chips, which is pretty cool--
the next generation of Intel
Xeon processors.
FRANCESC: So I'm
going to have to ask,
because I know that you are
more into hardware than I am,
because video games and stuff.
MARK: Sure.
FRANCESC: So why is this cool?
What kind of use
cases do you think
that these kind of
processors could help with?
MARK: So this is kind of cool.
I'm actually just
reading about it now.
But it is cool, because it
has certain implications
around floating
point performance.
And that's really useful
for genomics research,
[INAUDIBLE] rendering, data
analytics, stuff like that.
So it's pretty great if you're
doing heavy CPU computation
type things.
This sort of processor can
cut down your workload time
by quite a lot.
FRANCESC: So yeah,
I guess that that
might help basically any
kind of heavy simulation
that might not benefit
as much as they could
from our second cool thing
of the week, which is GPUs.
MARK: Yay!
FRANCESC: Yay!
So we have these [INAUDIBLE].
GPUs are now available for
Google Compute Engine and Cloud
Machine Learning.
MARK: Currently,
we have NVIDIA GPUs
that are available in
three GCP regions--
US East, Asia East 1, and
Europe East 1 as well.
I believe that eventually we're
going to have both AMD and GPU.
But right now, in open
beta, we have NVIDIA GPUs
available that you can connect
to Google Compute Engine
instances.
FRANCESC: So the cool thing
is that you can adapt up
to eight GPUs in a
single custom VM, which
is pretty amazing, especially
if you're running things
like TensorFlow or basically
any other software that
is GPU-accelerated.
If you add eight
GPUs, you're going
to see a huge, huge
increase in performance.
So definitely worth trying.
MARK: Yeah, definitely.
Cloud GPUs are tightly
integrated with our machine
learning platform,
so you're going
to see some big
improvements there.
FRANCESC: On top of
GCE, you also have it
on Cloud Machine Learning.
So again, all these things, like
TensorFlow specifically, they
benefit a lot from GPUs.
So if you're already
running something
on GCU or Cloud Machine
Learning that you
think might benefit from
it, go give it a try.
MARK: Cool.
So outside of hardware, there's
actually a really great blog
post that I would love to
highlight, especially since I
have some content in it.
FRANCESC: I was
going to say it's
a really great blog post
that I partly wrote, so hey.
MARK: So I didn't
write this one.
It just links to the
one that I wrote.
So if you are coming
to Next-- or possibly,
actually, if you're just
going to end up, after Next,
looking at some of the YouTube
videos that are available,
it can be a little
hard to work out
which sessions that you
might want to watch.
Because there's--
well, there's over 200.
So there's a lot of content.
So what we've done is we have a
slew of articles that have been
written by developer
advocates, such as myself
and Francesc and
teammates of ours,
all about which
sessions would you
like to go to if you belong
to a particular community,
such as if you do
a lot of Windows
development, a lot of
Ruby, if you're a game
developer, if you're really into
G Suite and app scripting type
stuff.
There's a lot of blog posts
here that you can take advantage
of to give you a curated list
of exactly which sessions you
really should be
going to go see.
FRANCESC: Yeah.
It is pretty cool.
I know that there's a
bunch of different sessions
that I had no idea they
existed, because there
are so many of them.
So definitely, reading
these curated lists of these
are the kinds of
things you might like
is definitely worth it,
especially if you're coming.
And if you're not
coming, still, you
should definitely read it,
because all of the sessions
are going to be online later on.
So it can be a nice reference
material to go and watch
a bunch of talks.
You can basically binge
watch Cloud Next later on.
MARK: Yeah, it's totally--
it's binge watch time.
You just curl up on a couch and
watch a whole bunch of videos.
FRANCESC: There you go.
So I guess that it's time to go
talk to our friend, John Wayne
Parrottt, about Python.
MARK: Let's go do that.
FRANCESC: So I'm
very happy to welcome
to the podcast one of our
dear colleagues, a developer
programs engineer by the
name of John Wayne Parrott.
Hey, John Wayne Parrott.
How are you doing?
JOHN WAYNE PARROTT: I'm
doing all right, man.
How about yourself?
FRANCESC: Very good.
Very, happy and very
excited about getting you
to the podcast finally after we
mentioned your name first time.
That was actually
almost a year ago.
It was on February
24, episode 14,
where we mentioned
one of the cool things
that you've built,
that [INAUDIBLE]
like platform on Kubernetes.
JOHN WAYNE PARROTT: Yeah.
It was a fun side project.
FRANCESC: Yeah.
It's been a long time.
But today, you're here
to talk about Python.
But before we do
that, why don't you
tell us a little bit about
you and what you do at Google.
JOHN WAYNE PARROTT:
Yeah, for sure.
So just like you guys, I'm
in developer relations.
But developer
programs engineering
doesn't really tell
you a lot about what
I do just off the cuff.
So I focus more on our developer
experience, so documentation,
tutorials, sample code,
and things like that,
and also just taking a
holistic view of the platform
and making sure
that developers who
identify as Python developers
feel at home on the Google
platform.
MARK: Cool.
So I don't do very much
Python, if any at all.
So why Python?
What makes Python great?
JOHN WAYNE PARROTT: So Python
is one of those languages
that you can absolutely
start your programming
career with Python.
It's a great language
for newcomers,
because it's very approachable.
But at the same time, it's also
an insanely powerful language.
It's general purpose.
It's used almost everywhere.
It's hard to find places
where you don't see somebody
using Python.
And it's an incredible language,
because it's so approachable,
but at the same time, you
can do so much with it.
And it can really
take you a long way.
So for me personally, I think
Python is really appealing
because I came from a C++
game development background.
And programming was always
this thing that I imagine.
It's always going
to be difficult.
It's never going to be easy.
And then when I discovered
Python, I'm like, wow,
this can be easy.
I can actually express programs
in a way that makes sense,
and I don't have to
struggle with this all day
long just to do
something simple.
So I think there's a
lot of appeal in Python.
And I think especially for web
applications and data analysis
applications, it's really
approachable and easy to use.
FRANCESC: So since we're
talking about the kind of things
you can do with
Python, why don't you
tell us a little bit about the
things you can do with Python
on the Google Cloud platform?
What is the involvement
of Google Cloud platform
with Python?
JOHN WAYNE PARROTT: So
there's essentially--
I guess you can think of
it like it's two buckets.
There's people who are writing
web applications in Python.
And of course,
Google Cloud Platform
has multiple hosting options.
You have Container Engine,
Compute Engine, App Engine.
And Python works
on all of those.
So you can run your
Python web application
on Google Cloud Platform,
and we'll host it for you.
And then on the other side of
things, all of our services,
such as Datastore storage
and, newly, Spanner,
you can talk to
those using Python.
So you can use our services with
our Python client libraries.
And even more than that,
things like Dataflow.
You can use Python to program
your Dataflow pipelines
and things like that.
So the Python is pretty
much-- everything
that you can do
on Cloud Platform,
you can do with Python.
MARK: Cool.
Now, the amount that
I know about Python--
I know there was the
time the crystal cracked,
the great schism.
So what version of Python
do we generally support?
I don't even know what the
ecosystem really looks like.
What's the deal with--
is it 2 versus 3?
Is that what's going on there?
JOHN WAYNE PARROTT:
So 2 versus 3
has been the debate
for many years.
So 3 came out several years ago.
I say several.
It was a long time ago
now when 3.0 came out.
And there were a lot of--
it was non-trivial to upgrade
a project from 2.7 to 3--
well, 2.6 at the time to 3.
So a lot of people
just stayed with 2.
Because if it's not
broke, don't mess with it.
So that caused a
little bit of trouble.
And a lot of libraries,
you know such as Django,
didn't port right away.
And that made it a lot harder
for people to adopt Python.
Because not only do they have
to change their application,
but the libraries they depend
on don't support by Python 3.
Now, the story is
completely different today.
Almost every major
Python package
supports both Python 2 and 3
with the exception of maybe one
or two, and there's
replacements for those.
And in general, the community
is very focused on Python 3
is the future--
well, not the future.
It's the present.
And we need to get
there as fast as we can.
The other thing that's driving
this adoption of Python 3
is that Python
Software Foundation
is going to stop supporting
Python 2 in 2020.
So they've been given a
doomsday, essentially.
There's actually a
Python doomsday clock
you can pull up that gives you
a countdown to 2020 when we can
stop worrying about Python 2.
So it's pretty
interesting stuff.
So in terms of where we focus--
we as in Google Cloud
Platform focus--
we definitely want
to support Python 3
while not leaving
behind the people who
are still using Python 2.
Because there is still a lot of
people who are using Python 2.
So when you look at
our client libraries,
and you look at Container Engine
and Compute Engine and App
Engine flexible
environment, Python 3
is available and supported.
We support Python 3.5 right
now with our container runtime
that runs on App Engine
Flexible and Container Engine.
And we we're about to
add 3.6 very shortly.
App Engine Standard
is a special case.
It's still on 2.7, because
most of the applications that
run on App Engine Standard
are pretty much using 2.7
and have no need to update.
But we are investing
in standard,
so I would expect that
that might change soon.
So keep your eyes open,
eyes peeled there.
FRANCESC: Cool.
So we can use App
Engine with Python 2.
What is the frameworks
that people normally
use for these kind of things?
I know that Flask, I
think, is one of them,
or it might be Puddle,
or maybe both, actually.
I'm not very sure.
Could you talk a little
bit about frameworks
that we support?
JOHN WAYNE PARROTT:
Sure, absolutely.
So we don't really make the
framework choice for you
in any of our hosting platforms.
Of course, we try to
follow the community.
And if you look at
the Python community,
a lot of people, when they
think about Python in web,
they immediately jump to Django.
Django is one of the
largest open source projects
within the Python community
and has a huge userbase.
And there's lots of plug-ins
and things like that for Django
that make it a lot easier
to accomplish tasks quickly
with Django.
So we definitely want to give
more attention to Django users,
because it's a huge
community base.
And it's actually
something we've
been working on over the
last year, is making sure
that there's tutorials that
fit in to a lot of what
Django users are looking for.
That said, the Python community
is actually about split,
about an even split
between Django and Flask.
Django is more this
larger framework.
It's very opinionated.
It tells you how to
structure your app,
and it gives you
a lot of batteries
included sort of thing.
Flask is more like a spartan,
minimalist framework.
I think it actually started
as an April Fool's joke,
and people just liked
the idea, and it just
kept going from there.
So I personally am a Flask user.
And all of our tutorials for
App Engine Flexible environment
are written in Flask, because
it's just a lot easier
to write a sample
application with Flask,
because there's a lot less code
involved, a lot less files,
and a lower barrier
of entry, essentially,
than trying to have a Django
app for every tiny sample
that we write.
FRANCESC: Cool.
So what about other domains
other than web servers?
Is there any support
for NumPy related
to Google Cloud Platform?
I could imagine
something like that for--
I don't know-- Dataflow
or Datalab or whatever.
Do you know anything about this?
JOHN WAYNE PARROTT: So
with Dataflow and Datalab,
you have this access to this
other domain of data scientist
stuff.
And in general,
our platform will
let you use whatever you want
and just get out of your way.
So if you're using
our container runtime
and running your data analysis
pipelines on Kubernetes,
our container runtime
contains everything
that you need to install
NumPy out of the box.
That is to say, you just drop it
in your requirements.txt file,
which is how you declare
dependencies in Python,
by the way, guys.
You just drop NumPy into
your requirements.txt,
and then it works.
It should just work.
And so we really just--
a lot of Python is--
the community has a lot
of opinionated ideas
about how to handle
dependencies,
how to deal with
installing things.
And we just want to support
that and get out of the way
so that we don't block
that sort of thing.
I think Datalab has NumPy
and SciPy pre-installed.
So you don't even have to
install those on that one.
I could be wrong on
that, so don't quote me.
But if it's not,
I know it should
be pretty straightforward
to install in Datalab.
Dataflow, I think that's
special purpose-built
for data processing.
So I imagine you wouldn't
have any problem using
your normal Python data
scientist-related libraries.
MARK: Excellent.
All right.
Cool.
So that sounds like we have at
least a pretty decent coverage
across Python.
But are there any new
releases or things
that are being actively worked
on that Python developers can
look forward to?
JOHN WAYNE PARROTT: Yeah.
I mentioned this.
I hinted at this earlier.
One of the things that
we're definitely doing is--
at least in my team--
is trying to make
sure there's plenty
of tutorials for Django users.
We definitely want Django users
to feel at home on Google Cloud
Platform.
And that means
highlighting products
such as Cloud SQL, which is
our hosted MySQL solution.
Because Django developers
are a lot more familiar
with a relational
database management
system than something like
Datastore, for instance.
So we're focusing
a bit on Django
over the coming months
and things like that.
But there's also-- there's
always new products being
released for Cloud Platform.
Just the other day,
we released Spanner.
And of course, that has a
Python client library on day 1,
and you can use
Spanner from Python
if you want an incredibly
high-scale database that
can do SQL queries.
MARK: That sounds cool.
Now I'm actually just curious.
We talked a couple of
times about Django.
Are there particular
challenges around running it
on Google Cloud?
Are there particular
platforms that it's better on?
Does it work better
on Kubernetes
than it does on App Engine
or something like that?
JOHN WAYNE PARROTT:
Yeah So I think it just
depends on your workload.
So Python-- I think if
you're doing some heavy data
processing, clearly you
don't want to use App Engine,
because App Engine is built
for stateless workloads.
But if you're writing
web front ends,
then App Engine
absolutely makes sense.
So I think it just all
comes down to your use case.
I think all of our
platforms are pretty
well-suited for running Python.
I think it's just a case
of what execution model is
going to best match.
MARK: We were just talking
specifically about Django.
JOHN WAYNE PARROTT: Oh, Django.
MARK: Yeah.
Is there a particular one
that's better for that?
JOHN WAYNE PARROTT: I would
say App Engine Flex is going
to give you the absolute best
out-of-the-box experience with
Django.
We purpose-built the
developer experience
for App Engine Flexible
to meet Python developers
where they are.
So for the most part, if
you have an application--
a Python web application that
has a requirements.txt file,
you can drop in a
really simple app.yaml
and deploy it to App Engline
Flexible without any changes,
typically.
You may have to change the
port that it's listening on,
but that is our goal.
Our goal is to be able
to take any Django app
and run it on App
Engine Flexible.
FRANCESC: So I'm
assuming that what
you were saying
about the port is
that you will need to read
the port from an environment
variable, something like that?
JOHN WAYNE PARROTT: Yeah.
We expose the port
environment variable,
which is always 80 80.
FRANCESC: That's [INAUDIBLE].
For Go, we're basically working
on exactly the same thing.
So you can just
drop it, and it just
works, which is pretty nice.
As a Go developer,
something that I'm slightly
jealous about for App Engine
is your amazing NDB library.
I don't know if you could
talk a little bit about it.
JOHN WAYNE PARROTT:
Everybody loves NDB.
Fun fact-- it was actually
written by Guido van Rossum.
The inventor of Python
himself wrote the NDB library.
So there's a lot of interesting
things in that library.
Our App Engine Standard
users absolutely love it.
However, it's not
currently available
outside of App Engine Standard.
But we know that users love
it, and we are definitely
looking into bringing
in that library
and making it available
to use everywhere.
So we want to rebase it on
top of the cloud platform--
Google Cloud Datastore API
instead of the App Engine
Datastore API so that
you can use it wherever.
FRANCESC: So for those that
do not know what NDB is--
and actually, I don't even
know what NDB stands for.
Could you use describe
it a little bit, please?
JOHN WAYNE PARROTT: Sure.
So NDB is our ORM, our Object
Relational Mapper for Datastore
for App Engine Standard.
It is named NDB because
it means New DB.
Because there was a
previous library for App
Engine Standard just called DB.
FRANCESC: That's a slightly
disappointing name.
JOHN WAYNE PARROTT: It's
a great name, I think.
So yeah, it's just an ORM.
So for Python developers,
if you're familiar with it,
it's like SQL Alchemy
or Django's ORM.
Then it's somewhat
similar to that.
You define your data
models as classes,
and then you can define
the property types on that.
And then, of course, the library
handles querying, and then
serialization, and
stuff like that.
MARK: And it also puts a
Memcache in front of it, too?
JOHN WAYNE PARROTT: Oh, yeah.
That's one of the really
cool features about NDB.
Because App Engine includes
a Memcache service,
NDB does write-through caching
for all of your entities.
So it's pretty neat.
And it works about
95% of the time
for everybody, which is great.
That's one of the
difficulties with porting it
outside of App Engine.
Because you either
have to provide
some sort of plug-in
interface to be
able to add different caching
layers-- because imagine
if you're running
on Compute Engine,
you may not have Memcache
available to you.
You may have Redis or
something like that.
So you want to be able to plug
in a different caching back
end, or not have a
caching back end if you
don't have anything available.
MARK: I'm curious--
is there anything
new and exciting in
the Python community
that you're particularly
excited about, new frameworks
or releases or anything
interesting like that?
JOHN WAYNE PARROTT: Oh, man.
Where do I start?
The Python community is always
growing and always evolving.
With the release of 3.6, we
got some really neat stuff.
We have this thing
called async I/O.
And in 3.6, it's no
longer experimental.
It's actually a
supported core part
of the Python standard library.
So async I/O gives us
something similar to Go's
go routines in Python.
So it allows us to
do this really cool
co-routine asynchronous code.
And people have done all
sorts of really cool things
with this.
I feel like maybe
late last year--
I may be getting my
timelines wrong here--
somebody released a plug-in
for Python's async I/O
that uses UV loop underneath
the covers, which is, I think,
the same invented I/O
that Node.js uses.
So it's blazingly fast.
So it's pretty cool.
And then somebody else built a
web framework on top of UV Loop
called Sanic, because
you have to go fast.
So Sanic is one of the
fastest web frameworks ever.
And it's just super cool stuff.
So with async I/O, you can do
a lot more with one process,
and you can do things like
use different event loops,
like UV loop, and get insane
network performance out
of your Python programs.
So one of the things I
have on my list to do
is actually write
an application using
Sanic that runs on
App Engine Flexible
so that we can be part of
this crazy, awesome movement
of async stuff
going on in Python.
FRANCESC: Nice.
That was actually what
I was going to ask you--
does this work on
App Engine Flex?
So perfect.
JOHN WAYNE PARROTT: It does.
I just haven't finished
polishing the thing.
So it works out of the
box on App Engine Flex.
There's no worries there.
Because it just works on Linux.
And if it works on
Linux, it probably
works in the container.
And if it works
in the container,
it will run on App Engine Flex.
So yeah, it's exciting stuff.
And I just need to
publish that sample,
because it's super awesome.
FRANCESC: So Google
is pretty involved
with open source communities.
Last time, we had
someone from Node.js.
We were talking about Node.js--
what is the name
of the community?
MARK: Node.js community?
FRANCESC: Node Foundation.
There you go.
So is there something similar
for the Python community?
And if so, how is
Google involved with it?
JOHN WAYNE PARROTT: Yeah.
We're so involved, I don't know
if I can mention everything.
So Google is one of the--
we've been using Python
forever at Google.
So outside of Cloud Platform,
just inside of Google
proper, we have a couple of
core maintainers of Python.
We sponsor PyCon
every year, I think.
I wouldn't say every year.
I think at least
the last two years,
we've sponsored PyCon
to my knowledge.
That's the most authoritatively
I can speak on that.
So we sponsor PyCon.
Typically, the
Googlers talk there.
Googlers are really heavily
involved in the open source
community around Python.
In cloud specifically,
I know that we
are working with a lot of open
source libraries like Apache
Libcloud to help integrate with
Google Cloud Platform services
and things like that.
Myself, I've helped
out with urllib3,
which is a very popular
Python open source
package for HTTP requests.
And in general, we try
to be as open as we can,
which I think is really positive
for the Python community.
In my opinion,
there's nothing more
important than open source.
And I'm happy that
I'm in a spot where
I can do a lot of
contributing to open source.
MARK: Cool.
You mentioned PyCon.
Is PyCon the only
event we tend to go to,
or should people expect to see
Googlers at other such Python
events as well?
JOHN WAYNE PARROTT:
Well, what's great
about PyCon is that
there's not just one.
There's PyCon in Canada.
There's PyCon in Japan, I think.
So there's a bunch of them.
And we tend to be involved in
quite a few of those, I think.
I think our
colleague, Ian Lewis,
tends to do the ones that
are over in Japan and stuff
like that.
So I think we're really involved
in those PyCon-type events.
I don't know if there's any
other huge PyCon-level events.
That is really--
the community likes
to be centralized in that way.
It's the big one for everybody.
So we're super involved in that.
I don't know.
I don't know the answer to
that question, essentially.
MARK: That's all right.
That's good.
FRANCESC: We're
running out of time.
But is there any other topics
or announcements or whatever
that you'd like to
mention before we finish?
JOHN WAYNE PARROTT:
Not at the moment.
FRANCESC: That's totally fair.
JOHN WAYNE PARROTT: If I told
you, I'd have to kill you.
FRANCESC: Oh, wow.
MARK: Oh.
So something cool is coming,
but we don't know what it is.
FRANCESC: You should kill
us and the whole audience.
OK.
That's a lot of
people, but whatever.
OK.
Well, then, thank you so
much for taking the time
to talk to us about Python.
And let's see when you
come back and tell us what
secrets you're hiding today.
JOHN WAYNE PARROTT: All right.
Looking forward to it.
FRANCESC: Take care.
JOHN WAYNE PARROTT: Thanks.
FRANCESC: Well, thanks again
to John Parrott for such
an interesting interview.
I personally have
written lots of Python,
but I have been out of the
community for quite a while,
so it's always nice to see
what's going on and learning
a little bit what are the plans
with Python 2 versus Python 3,
the kind of support we
have at Google Cloud
Platform, et cetera.
So very cool interview.
MARK: Yeah.
Thanks so much for
joining us, John.
There's a lot of friends
of mine who are at Python,
so I'm sure they're
going to appreciate it.
So moving on to our
question of the week.
Francesc, you were
telling me earlier
of a question that came from one
of the members of your workshop
while you were having
your travels in India.
He was talking
about transactions
and being able to
transactionally store data,
say, in some sort of
storage system, and then
also being able to
send an email such
that, say, the email failed.
Then the transaction on the
data storage would draw back.
Or if the data storage
didn't go through properly,
then the email wouldn't go out.
How can I do that
transactionally in that sort
of situation on Google Cloud?
FRANCESC: Yeah.
So to be more specific, this was
in the context of App Engine.
I have this Go Web
workshop that is basically
writing Go web
applications on App Engine.
And we're already
using Datastore.
And I mentioned that you can
use the Mail API, Mail Service
API from App Engine to
send emails very easily.
And the question
was actually that.
So imagine that I want to store
something in the data store
after sending an
email, or that I
want that email only to be sent
when the Datastore thing has
worked.
So I want to basically have
the sending of an email
as part of a transaction.
This is something that
you cannot really do.
But there's actually ways of
mitigating that issue, which
is one of the best ways
to do it is actually
by using task queues.
So task queues-- I think we've
talked about it a long time
ago.
But task queues
is a little thing
that allows you to
schedule something
to be done later
on at some point.
So in this case,
you could say, oh, I
want to store something
in the data store,
and then I want to
schedule sending
the email at some point.
Now, the cool thing is
that storing something
in the task queue can be done
inside of a transaction, inside
of a Datastore transaction.
So you can atomically
decide if you
should be sending
that email or not
according to the success status
of a transaction indexer, which
is actually very powerful.
Because then you can
use the same principle
to apply it to
whatever you want.
MARK: Oh, so that's cool.
So if I am doing something in
Datastore with a transaction,
I can then transactionally
also send off task queues
to fire something
in the background.
But if any part in
that chain fails,
then those task queues
and that data storage
will all roll back atomically.
FRANCESC: Exactly.
So you don't need
to go and be like,
oh, I add something to the task
queue, and then it was like,
oh, let me get it back.
There's no need of doing that.
You can just use a
transaction as you
would do in a data store.
So
MARK: Awesome.
So I could send an
email, or an SMS,
or just do something
even totally crazy,
like compute a whole new
thing if I wanted to.
FRANCESC: Or you can lock some
metrics, or whatever cool thing
you want to do.
It is quite simple.
MARK: Awesome.
Well, thank you so much
for explaining that
to us, Francesc.
FRANCESC: It's a pleasure.
MARK: Wonderful.
So I believe-- I know you
are off to Mumbai next.
What are you doing there?
FRANCESC: Yeah.
So I am today, while
we're recording, in Pune,
but I'm going to Mumbai
tomorrow to run a workshop.
But by the time this
episode will be out,
I will be flying over
somewhere between India and San
Francisco, coming back
to the United States,
and getting ready
for Cloud Next.
MARK: Excellent.
So pretty much when
this comes out,
I'll be at the Game
Developers Conference,
right in the middle of it.
But I think-- yeah, I
will be at Next as well.
We're going to have a
pretty fancy booth setup.
I think I'm pretty
excited about it.
There have been talks about
doing daily episodes, so
hopefully that all
comes together as well.
I'm not going to promise
anything just in case that--
FRANCESC: We'll
see how that works.
It's a big challenge
right there.
MARK: It's a big
challenge right there.
But we're definitely going
to be looking for people
to come by the booth,
do short interviews,
come hang out with us, get
some t-shirts, some stickers.
We're really looking forward
to seeing people at Next.
FRANCESC: Yeah.
And I guess that if
you're going to come,
it would be a very nice
thing to do to warn us
and to get in touch with us.
The best way to do this
is we have Twitter.
MARK: @GCPpodcast.
FRANCESC: We have Google+.
MARK: +GCPpodcast.
FRANCESC: We have a subreddit.
MARK: /r/gcppodcast.
FRANCESC: We do have
a web page, too.
MARK: Gcppodcast.com.
FRANCESC: And an email.
MARK: hello@gcppodcast.
FRANCESC: And finally,
we're also on Slack.
And that is the one
that is a mouthful.
MARK: Slack is hash podcast
on the Google Cloud Platform
community Slack that you can
reach at bit.ly/gcp-slack.
FRANCESC: Wow.
Amazing.
Good job.
MARK: Nailed it.
FRANCESC: So send
us your questions.
We got a bunch of questions
during the last week,
and we'll be using some of
those for our next episode.
So do not think that we do
not read those questions.
We read every single one of
your emails, and we love them.
So keep them going.
MARK: Yes.
Thank you very much.
Well, Francesc, thank you
for joining me yet again
for another episode.
FRANCESC: Thank you, Mark.
And thank you all for listening.
MARK: See you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]